[Music]
hey what's up guys it's time on the set
of spider-man far from home I have an
exciting announcement
the brothers Trust is going to be
offering an opportunity for you to fly
from anywhere around the world to people
to come and hang out with me on set here
with all the guys at Marvel it's gonna
be amazing we are gonna put you up in a
West End hotel for three days we're
gonna give you $1,000 spending money
you're gonna get to hang out and set for
a day with me I'll give you a signed
photo you can see the whole process the
hair makeup or costume the filming
everything and it's gonna be amazing so
go to the brothers trust website when I
tell you to because I don't think we've
been announced the details yet but we
will it'll be amazing so stay tuned and
it'll be great
hey everybody is Charlie what a surprise
Tom Holland giving away low-key spoilers
on the set of spider-man far from home
if you didn't know what's going on here
this confirms that he wears the original
stark tech suit during that movie but
when I was posting about this this
morning I got a whole bunch of questions
about the timeline about what this means
for the larger plot of the film and
Marvel phase four so we got to break all
this down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos there's a new brand of
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber or leave a comment on the
video uh name a new winner at the end of
this so if you don't know what's going
on here this is him on set between takes
talking about his charity that he's
gonna be launching really soon all the
actors have charities that they launched
they try to do funny videos because they
haven't started The Avengers for pres to
her yet Tom Holland is like the resident
spoiler bro that has to represent onset
Ruffalo's out blowing in the wind
working on other projects before they
meet back up for Avengers for reshoots
but because everybody gets upgrades in
every brand new movie and he's wearing
this people like does he not get a new
suit during spider-man far from home
what's happening is he's just gonna go
back to this at least Karen's coming
back if you guys remember suit lady she
was barely a thing during infinity war
as was Friday I'll explain the weirdness
with the artificial intelligence and why
they weren't around when they went to
Titan
but if you understand how Marvel threads
the through lines through these films
like Civil War
spider-man homecoming than infinity war
then you kind of know what's going on
with spider-man in his different suits
when we pick up at the beginning of
spider-man far from home so for those of
you asking about the timeline questions
when does this movie actually take place
there was some more confusion about that
on Twitter this morning this movie picks
up minutes within minutes of the end of
Avengers 4 Kevin Feige described it as
spider-man going on vacation to Europe
with his friends in between school
sessions so this is happening during the
summer before school starts up we have
our farewell tour of the og Avengers
I've already done a couple videos about
how I think they're gonna end Avengers 4
I'll link that Iron Man video at the end
of this there was a deleted scene with
some heavy foreshadowing that fixed the
universe time sort of resets a little
bit so that all the avengers remember
what happened but only a couple weeks
have passed so it's not like years and
years in the future when this movie
picks up whether they stitch together a
new reality or they just reset the
timeline things officially end a couple
weeks after this like not a whole lot of
time passes between the beginning of
infinity war and where they end in the
timeline at the end of Avengers 4 even
though the Avengers themselves will have
been through several years of this they
have their memorial for all the Avengers
that died and will not be coming back I
know we all have theories about that
it'll be easier to theory craft about
who's not coming back after we get our
first trailer it's gonna be a couple
months before that happens but you have
a beat to remember the Fallen then you
have that happier ending moment that I
talked about in my iron band video then
everybody kind of goes their separate
ways into whatever it is that they're
doing next
so spider-man having been on his latest
Avengers retreat died brought back to
life
probably in dire need of a vacation he's
probably gonna take it better than
Ironman took the events of the Avengers
film I talked about how crazy iron man
went after Avengers how the Russo said
that he's gonna be emotionally damaged
forever after having watched spider-man
die in his arms spider-man won't be
quite as affected as that but imagine
you go through something that's
stressful with Thanos you're gonna need
a vacation so that's how things start
and because it picks up minutes after
where they end in Avengers 4 you can
see how he might want to decompress by
going back to being a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
meaning that he gives the start tech
suit back to Tony Stark it's stored at
the Avengers base so it's always there
if he needs it so he's left with the
original stark tech suit he was wearing
it underneath the iron spider armor -
remember you just formed around him
[Music]
smells like a new so while he's fighting
here on Titan he's wearing both of those
suits one of those is just being worn
like an outer layer of armor so once he
takes that off he's just left with what
he had when he started which is the
classic suit so he has that with him
when he goes on vacation we know a
little bit about what's going on with
Mysterio we know the vultures coming
back we know scorpion I've already done
a video about the villains a spider-man
far from home how it's a low-key
sinister six without actually having a
full six members so something happens
that tips off this Mysterio plot he
tries to save things they end up jumping
around Europe because they're gonna be
globe-hopping a little bit during the
film and because these comic-book movies
are built on merchandising licensing toy
sales yes of course there are gonna be a
whole bunch of toy lines and they're not
just gonna resell the figure from
spider-man Home Coming they're gonna
need a new suit funny enough it's all
about the toys you think you know oh
he's got a new big challenge he needs to
upgrade his suit to match that challenge
whatever Mysterio and the sinister six
are gonna throw at him now it's really
about toys there was actually some
leaked concept art that showed a
slightly different version of what he's
wearing now it still looks like classic
comic-book spider-man but it seems like
it dials back on some of the stark
visual features without maybe losing any
of that additional technology so you
have to imagine that even if the costume
looks simpler it's probably more
advanced most notable things about this
are the different spider symbols on his
chest and on his back and there's no
black bands that run across the costume
we got all kinds of theories about how
he's gonna get that new suit if sharees
gonna have anything to do with it if
it's gonna be a very international based
spider-man movie pretty easy slam dunk
could be get some help from one of the
other Avengers we've learned that Nick
Fury and Maria Hill are gonna have small
roles during the film we don't know what
they're gonna be doing but you have to
imagine that if it's gonna be a problem
that's this big and goes across the
entire world then Nick Fury is probably
going to get involved in some way but a
lot of that is just speculation we know
that there's gonna be another big
Avenger crossing over into it we don't
know who that's going to be even though
signs are pointing towards Robert Downey
jr. continuing in some fashion in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
it could be somebody besides Tony Stark
when we learn about the new a-list cameo
it was implied that it would be somebody
else but because he's so tied to the
Tony Stark character it would be weird
if there were
nothing Iron Man at all in the movie
maybe one of those funny phone calls
where Tony's in a different part of the
world trying to give him a little pep
talk
oh I'm not here thank God this place has
Wi-Fi and you would be toast right now
Thank You Nashville you're at it
so hopefully that explains a little bit
about why he's wearing this costume here
we don't know which scene he's filming
it just makes sense that he would be
wearing this at the beginning of
spider-man far from home his battles
with the villains lead him to upgrade it
with a little bit of help from someone
else because while he is really smart
and I do think that given enough time he
could make himself his own spider suit
the level of tech that we have access to
now because of what went on in the Black
Panther movie and what Iron Man has been
doing with nanotech he's just so great
that it would be really weird if
spider-man didn't take advantage of that
remember he's officially an Avenger now
which means that he's going to be a
little bit more social with the other
Avengers going forward let me know in
the comments though what do you want his
next new suit to do now stealth mode is
like probably the most practical thing
that we haven't got into yet even though
I bet that there's actually a stealth
mode built into the stark tech suit and
they just cut that out of spider-man
homecoming as far as suit lady Karen I
expect her to continue like it would
have been weird if Paul Bettany had
stopped playing the vision character
during the Iron Man films I think they
want to keep a level of consistency with
that AI voice so however many movies the
Spider Man is in from here on out suit
lady just comes back to be that person
maybe someday they'll pay off Jocasta
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner fqr gaming please email me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to watch the
Avengers forecast talk about the quantum
realm and how important it is and click
here for that brand new venom trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]